it is starting to get stunningly stupid
with the earth Korea situation that the
United States finds itself in I
mentioned yesterday after the summit
that Donald Trump clearly thinks that he
is won and his followers have been
tricked into thinking the exact same
thing and as I pointed out yesterday the
so-called deal that was made is almost
identical to many past deals where North
Korea has agreed in principle to
denuclearization and to seek peace or
whatever else but most importantly
nothing was actually done and most
importantly in this negotiation nothing
has actually taken place so far we have
a very vague and non-committal single
piece of paper signed by Donald Trump
and Kim jong-un
Trump has said that he's stopping
military exercises near North Korea
North Korea hasn't yet proven that it's
going to do any of the things that Kim
jong-un signed off that he would be
doing and what is absolutely stunning is
that in the last 12 or so hours North
Korea's state media agency KCNA is now
claiming that Donald Trump has agreed to
lift all sanctions on North Korea is
this true Trump didn't mention it it's
possible that KCNA is lying but at the
same time Donald Trump did say in this
bizarre press conference after the
summit that after they signed the piece
of paper there were a bunch of toss ins
both Kim jong-un and Donald Trump
mentioned a bunch of extra stuff of
course only verbally not in writing
anywhere that they were going to be
doing so has Trump agreed to lift
sanctions on North Korea in exchange for
nothing actually being done yet White
House hasn't commented at least as of a
couple of hours ago but if indeed Trump
did lift sanctions on North Korea it's
another one of these examples of Trump
doing something in exchange for nothing
because North Korea hasn't done anything
yet and there are trumpets who will hear
me and they'll write in and they saw
David I thought you were against war and
against conflict why don't you want to
get along with North Korea and I do want
to get along with North Korea but North
Korea is a brutal regime
with for starvation political killings
totalitarian control and no master
negotiator which Donald Trump claims to
be should start just giving concessions
away like candy before you either get
something back or at least get an
assurance something binding that you're
going to get something back and this
dangerous blindness to reality is
particularly evident in Donald Trump's
recent tweets this morning Donald Trump
took to Twitter I guess as he was
arriving back from Singapore saying
first quote before taking office people
were assuming that we were going to war
with North Korea President Obama said
that North Korea was our biggest and
most dangerous problem no longer sleep
well tonight then also tweeting just
landed a long trip but everybody can now
feel much safer than the day I took
office there is no longer a nuclear
threat from North Korea meeting with Kim
jong-un was an interesting and very
positive experience north Korea has
great potential for the future the
degree of nuclear threat from North
Korea hasn't changed from 48 hours ago
because nobody has done anything yet Kim
jong-un has made vague non-binding sort
of commitments to start making changes
at some point in the future the idea
that Donald Trump would come back and
remember we are now in a world where his
statements on Twitter are to some degree
official statements that they
communicate what the president truly
believes is going on the idea that Trump
thinks the nuclear threat from North
Korea has been eliminated is stunningly
ignorant and dangerous he signed a piece
of paper agreeing to things that North
Korea has previously agreed to do and
then for subsequently ignored and Trump
is literally tweeting no more nuclear
threat from North Korea on the off
chance that this doesn't work out Trump
in apparently some kind of exhaustion
delirium from being awake more than 24
hours told the truth yesterday before
leaving Singapore and Trump said listen
you know what
if kim jongwan doesn't stick to what he
said he was going to do I'll come up
with some excuse as to why it's not my
fault anyway bizarre video of Trump
being strangely honest after the summit
take a look I think he's I think
honestly I think he's gonna do these
things I may be wrong I mean I may stand
before you in six months and say hey I
was wrong I don't know that I'll ever
admit that but I'll find us I'll find
some kind of an excuse okay one or two
one more come on Trump's joking about it
but that's actually exactly what he will
do right it's it's it's brilliant in its
evil genius he has claimed victory
including on Twitter saying nuclear
threat from North Korea is over we did
it we won North Korea is no longer a
problem and he's doing this by accepting
at face value the sort of statements
that previously have been immediately
ignored by North Korean leaders and he
straight-up told us he said in public in
front of a camera if it doesn't work out
in six months or whenever he won't admit
that he's wrong he'll just come up with
some excuse for right why it wasn't his
fault anyway in his exhaustion he made a
joke that is actually what he will do
but then the midterms might be over and
he might be well on his way to
re-election by that time yeah maybe a
misstep I think I found you think I
think that this is exactly because his
supporters don't care right they'll
forget about this and in six months
Trump will say I did my part I made
every effort I got the commitments I
wanted to get who could have predicted X
Y or Z which led to Kim jong-un
ultimately not doing it it sounds like
wishful thinking on both sides right
North Korea is saying that the u.s. is
going to pull all of its sanctions the
u.s. is saying that North Korea is going
to denuclearize
really probably I mean probably not none
of those things are gonna happen but it
allows both sides to claim victory and
that's what they want they didn't want
this to be a waste of time and that's
the priority for Kim jong-un right he
wants to win the propaganda war both
internationally but importantly within
his own country and I mean serious
question if you're a Iran right and you
see this happening even if we don't know
exactly which of these claims are true
and which of these claims aren't true
what do you start doing if you are Iran
because if it's true that Trump is
lifting sanctions on North Korea and
he's going to help them build luxury
hotels and
bring great amounts of business and
tourism dollars or whatever if you see
Trump doing that with one of the most
brutal and oppressive regimes in the
world while trying to impose tariffs on
our allies what do you do if you are a
country like for example Iran not a
rhetorical question that's a real
question I have the video you just
watched was made possible by support
from you please go to patreon.com slash
david pakman show you can make a pledge
of as little as $1 per month and every
dollar helps to support the work that
we're doing particularly in light of the
YouTube ad boycott which has been really
bad